[Music]
good evening everyone
at the heart of our understanding of the
universe is the theory that just four
forces govern everything the strong and
weak nuclear forces the electromagnetic
force and gravity the first three of
those forces are central to what is
known as the standard model of
fundamental physics
but now an extraordinary result
announced in april of 2021
threatens that whole framework and with
it potentially the entire account of
fundamental physics some have claimed
that the experiment points to an
entirely new force something that is
neither contained nor predicted by our
current theories
could this new discovery prove mistaken
or do we have to be in our current
theory painstakingly developed over many
decades or might this be a catalyst for
a radically new account that could
change the way we understand everything
from the forces of nature to the big
bang
well here to discuss and debate those
questions we have a fantastic panel um
first of all rene fatimi is the
simulations manager for this
groundbreaking experiment called muon g2
as professor of physics at the
university of kentucky
renee is an expert in accelerator-based
nuclear and particle physics
as regent's professor of physics at
arizona state university paul davies
works on the big questions of existence
ranging from the origin of life to the
nature of time to the foundational
questions of quantum mechanics he is the
recipient of the highly prestigious
templeton prize for his work on the
deeper implications of science and he's
a best-selling author of many popular
science books
chris impe is um a professor of one of
the largest astronomy departments uh in
the usa at the university of arizona he
has over 200 scientific publications
he's won grants from nasa and the
national science foundation he's written
several popular science books too and he
also regularly travels to teach science
to tibetan monks so we're going to begin
um with the question is this
the most significant experimental result
in physics of the 21st century so far
we're going to talk a little bit later
on about exactly what this is what the
experiment
found but first of all we're going to
talk about what the the real
implications are for in the from the
point of view of the speakers and we're
going to start uh with renee fattamy so
renee over to you
oh thank you so much philip so thank you
for the invitation and the kind
introduction
so this is a very interesting question
because we have made some absolutely
stunning experimental
discoveries in physics in just the last
20 years which is pretty impressive
because two decades isn't an extremely
long time in the world of physics so um
so two
really recent discoveries that come to
mind that i think are relevant for our
discussion are the discovery of
gravitational waves that uh that was
long awaited right and and can confirm
einstein's prediction from general
relativity and then of course there was
the discovery of the higgs boson so
which was a confirmation of one of the
core predictions of the standard model
which you refer to which is really um
in some
sense the theory underlying all of
particle physics um so both of these
discoveries were highly anticipated and
eagerly awaited so and and they
confirmed foundational theoretical work
so it would be difficult to say i think
that the g minus two result from
fermilab is more significant so i would
instead say that um
that it may be one of the most
transformational results of the 21st
century and transformational because
unlike the two discoveries i just
pointed out
um
it's shedding light on physics that's
outside of our current uh theoretical
frameworks right and so that's what's
that's what's so compelling about it and
um so in particle physics we've been
living in in sort of this um state of
growing dissonance right we how can the
standard model of particle physics do
such a splendid job of predicting
something like the higgs in fact
predicting every single particle and and
finding that it that that that's within
its framework um and also doing such um
precision uh predictions so for example
it can predict two parts per trillion
accurately predict two parts per
trillion via the um magnetic moment of
the electron right so so how can an
experiment you know a theory that is um
on such firm ground also be completely
agnostic about the things that we know
right that that there's more matter than
antimatter uh how could it have
absolutely no idea uh where dark matter
comes from so we're living in this state
of of of tension and we've been living
there for you know decades now and um
and it's just and it's just growing and
and so i think um
this experiment results which will only
improve in precision because the only
release 10
of our existing data and this result
which is of course
partnership with theoretical predictions
and they will also improve their
precision so these these results will go
forward and and improve and precision um
i think what it's done is it's really
poked a hole in the darkness right
that's what it's done it's given us a
guiding light to where we can start to
go to resolve this tension and what's
exciting is once you see one pinhole
often other pinholes come up for example
there's this new result from lhcb
about the ratio of b decays to mu plus
mu minus and e plus e minus it's a 3.1
sigma deviation so it's not discovery
but it's something that's um that that
may be pushing us all in the same
direction
and i can guarantee that the community
is right now working very hard on
following through on those leads as we
speak
fantastic thank you so much and uh maybe
we'll hear more about that other result
later i hope we have time for that
um so now i'm turning to paul davies and
uh paul uh just to remind you the
question is is this the most significant
experimental result in physics of the
21st century so far
well like renee i had also picked the
discovery of the higgs boson and
gravitational waves
as being a very hard act to follow these
are stupendous discoveries with great
implications
and they tie theory and experiment
together in a wonderful way the
experiment we're talking about now with
the muon uh is something
that stands out uh from
uh standard theory the standard model uh
that you introduced philip
and so it's in a different category and
really only time will tell the big issue
here i think uh for
most theorists is
uh is this uh muon result a window uh
into some radically new physics like an
additional force for example
or is it just telling us that we have to
tweak
the existing standard model just make a
little change here and there and then
everything will be good we don't know
that it's too too early to say but what
is very clear and has been clear for a
long time is that there must be new
physics beyond the standard model
rene mentioned dark matter
most of the matter in the universe is
not the stuff of which you me and the
stars are made it's something else we
don't know what it is the standard model
uh doesn't tell us but we've known about
this dark matter for really a very long
time so that evidence quite literally
outweighs all the other evidence it
stands out like a sore thumb it's not
the only thing though uh for example
neutrinos which when they were first
proposed was supposed to be massless it
was discovered over 20 years ago
that they
actually have a tiny mass and that is
not encompassed within the standard
model either so
we know those new physics out there to
be discovered and what's frustrating
is that the best particle accelerators
we have like the large hadron collider
for example
is not
really giving us a clue about what is
going on although it will get tweaked up
next year and so it may be that some
further evidence will arise from that
so i should say that uh tiny effects
sometimes do lead to very great results
and the one that sticks out in my mind
is the discovery that the laws of
physics are not quite perfectly time
symmetric this goes back to the 1960s uh
just a slight discrepancy in the time
reversal symmetry of the fundamental
laws and yet it opens up
vast new areas of inquiry and so tiny
effects can lead to big consequences i'm
a bit skeptical about the fifth faults
during my career there have been a
number of fifth forces proposed and then
didn't seem to go anywhere
so i'm sort of sitting on the fence
for that one and i just finished by
saying that uh surely there will be
consequences for cosmology
thank you paul um and chris i'm going to
now come to you and again the question
is is this the most significant
experimental result of the century so
far
okay thank you well i think
all of us are in accord on uh the fact
that there are a couple of other uh
prime contenders and i would
uh you know by a nose put the discovery
of gravitational waves as the most
amazing discoveries so far in this
century
not because the higgs wasn't spectacular
but the higgs was essentially closing
the chapter on the book the book of the
standard model it was of course keenly
anticipated it was a spectacular result
and it of course hovered in this
tricky three to four sigma level
uh detection before a second season of
data was added and it was nailed so it
was another good sign that if you just
get more data you can eventually trust
your result
but for me gravitational waves is
is more than spectacular because it's
just an exquisite experimental precision
to detect them in the first place
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas